a couple days ago I was watching this
scene in Andor and this shot pops up and
the first thing that crosses my mind is
I recognize that not in a oh I've seen
that in another show or film before but
in a I've been there kind of way and
then I immediately thought no that's
crazy obviously I haven't been there
this is clearly a fake location but then
it cut to the next shot which just
further confirmed my feeling look at
this footage I shot in London over the
summer at a place called The Barbican
Center I don't have any shots that line
up exactly with the shots from Andor but
you can tell based on certain design
features and elements that this is the
real location where they shot this
course on scene for Andor obviously the
version in the show is heavily modified
and extended with VFX but I think this
approach of grounding the visual effects
in and or within real world physicality
and locations plays a big role in why
the show feels so real and lived in
Andor is 100 my favorite post Disney
Star Wars piece of media so far kind of
low-key a Star Wars fan I always thought
the world was cool and the original
trilogy are undeniable Classics but I
honestly stopped watching a lot of the
newer Disney stuff because it just
wasn't meeting the standards of
Storytelling that I find enjoyable for a
lot of the stuff I like to spend time
watching most of it feels like an
executive or producer was looking for
something to make that would be
successful and then trying to make that
rather than telling a story in the Star
Wars world because they had an actually
interesting or compelling story to tell
but I think Andor is great to me it's
everything I wanted from a Star Wars
reboot it doesn't just rehash things
we've already seen or try to go bigger
and better instead it explores this
interesting world and story from a
completely fresh perspective I want to
dig into why I've been enjoying the show
so much why I think it feels so real and
I'll keep the video spoiler for free so
you can watch it no matter how much of
the show you've seen let's compare the
opening of two different Star Wars shows
in the Obi-Wan show see how this shot
starts on the wide of the VFX and then
pulls back to include the parts of the
scene that are real
to me it looks kind of strange and fake
this whole sequence feels off down to
the weird camera shake that it looks
like they're adding in post
now compare that to the opening of Andor
what are the big differences here there
are three different techniques being
used kind of all together in this
opening that show up throughout the show
that I want to highlight the first
element is the priority given to the
real elements of the scene Andor first
establishes the very tangible physical
elements of the scene the light rain and
movement from the point of view
available to a human and then it
transitions into showing the VFX
elements that are added in post in the
background
I think doing things this way makes the
VFX feel a lot more cohesive for some
reason we see the real stuff which we
can kind of intuitively know is real and
then within that context the VFX stuff
feels like a part of that reality go in
the other direction and when we see the
VFX stuff we kind of know subconsciously
that it's fake and then we have this
sense that the real stuff is just
existing within the fake stuff which
feels much less cohesive to me the
second technique is to focus on sensory
details
charges loitering at the scene of a
crime walking an Unleashed massive
animal fouling
this helps ground the visual effects but
it's also just a part of good World
building throughout the show I didn't
tell you how wrong you were about Uncle
Harlow
but you will the crackle of a campfire
the feeling of Brokenness to a piece of
equipment
the texture and sound of food
you can live on that you may question
Your Existence after a few days the glow
of sunlight coming through a window onto
a character's face
these are the sensory details that make
the world the characters exist and feel
like you could touch it and feel it
because
they are touching it and feeling it
these sensory details go I think a long
way towards making it feel like the
characters exist within a
multi-dimensional space aren't just
standing on a set or in front of a green
screen
and this is one way the show really
benefits from shooting on location
there's been a lot of discussion about
the other Star Wars shows use of the
volume and I think this technique can be
really effective and has been a step up
from just shooting on a green screen for
a lot of the work that these shows are
doing but there will always be things
that are just harder to get in a studio
for a scene like this the real fire the
water dripping from the ceiling and the
way you can see their breath can all
happen naturally when you're filming on
location but would take tons of effort
to actually recreate on a set
memorable isn't it
the third Technique we see in this
opening and that's used throughout the
show very effectively is perspective we
don't just swoop in from above on a
digital landscape of this city we see it
from the walkway From andor's
perspective a lot of times these days if
I'm being honest my eyes just kind of
glaze over when I see these kind of
digital wide establishing shots for me
so often they don't actually do anything
towards making me understand what the
characters are experiencing or what the
place feels like when I'm watching a
show like this and I'm trying to get
emotionally invested in what the
characters are experiencing I don't want
to feel like I'm riding in a helicopter
over the location the characters are
standing in I want to feel like I'm
standing in the location with them one
of the things that and or does really
well is show us the details of the
worlds from an inside perspective you're
actually looking at and seeing these
worlds from the same perspective as the
characters and these shots put you in
their shoes a lot of shows jump from a
wide establishing VFX shot straight to
close-ups within a scene on a green
screen or within a smaller set and when
they do that they skip past the portions
where we as the viewer get to see the
locations in the same way we often
experience locations in our real lives
the show's use of perspective goes far
beyond just how the VFX are presented
and it's a big part of what I love about
the show we also experience the story
from the perspective of the characters
that are within it as the audience we
know about a lot of the big level huge
Star Wars ships and politics and events
that are taking place on a grander scale
but the characters in this story don't
have that broad overview experience
they're operating with limited knowledge
and trying their best to do what they
can to further their Rebellion while
they have to make judgments based on the
little amount of information they know
and the Show puts us inside that
perspective we don't get information or
get to see things that the individual
characters don't get to see I mean
imagine you're a character who spent
their whole life on a minor planet just
minding your own business and maybe
you've heard about a star destroyer but
you've never seen one and suddenly this
appears in your sky
terrifying
recontextualizing this big iconic Thing
by showing it from a completely
different perspective is a great way to
breathe some fresh life into a cool
piece of World building that has almost
become stale and commonplace in the Star
Wars Canon at this point
[Applause]
really that we've never seen these ships
from the perspective of the ground
before in Star Wars media but what Andor
really commits to is only showing us
these things from the character's
perspective the way they use the ships
in this show is closer to how a good
horror film director uses a monster in
their movies
talking
[Music]
they showed just little bits here and
there and it's more the implication of
what that means than actually seeing it
that creates suspense and drama for the
viewers
a lot of what I'm talking about here is
not any one thing but ultimately what I
would describe as the show having a
specific Vision what makes this illusion
of reality work is everything working
together the props the cinematography
the set design the costume design all of
it is in service of the story and also
telling that story in a specific way in
an article for Rolling Stone lead actor
Diego Luna said something that I think
encapsulates the vision for the show
really well we are stressing that change
and Revolution happen when regular
people decide to do something it's just
regular people trying to survive in the
darkest time in this galaxy and finding
out they can't take it anymore it's
about a system that is choking Society
the theme of the Rebellion being driven
and fueled by Regular People isn't just
created by the writing and what the
show's about it's reinforced by the
style of the show The regularness and
everydayness of the characters is is
conveyed through the show's commitment
to creating this sense of reality it's
conveyed through tiny things like the
fact that the characters are actually
eating and drinking frequently
throughout the show because these are
just regular people going about their
lives trying to figure out how to create
or squash a rebellion at the same time
I couldn't sleep
it's natural
I need to be at my best Andor is doing
something that I think is really
original within the Star Wars world it's
stepping away from this huge feeling of
destiny fate and Mythos that runs
through most of the Canon it's not that
that's inherently better but I think
doing that allows the show to explore
some complex themes and new territory in
a way that wasn't really possible before
in any of the other Star Wars stuff it's
saying what if we looked at the
rebellion and really examined the parts
that aren't about shooting a huge ship
down with lasers or training to become
an elite warrior class so you can
fulfill your destiny and save the Galaxy
it's saying what if we examine the
complex moral and ethical dilemmas faced
by each individual as they feel cornered
into fighting for what they believe in
what if we focused in on the compromise
in the gray areas to me the beauty of
this show is all the characters
surrounding Cassian Andor an
opportunistic mercenary who gets caught
up in the Rebellion he knows nothing
about any of it the show explores with
Nuance how every character has to make
sacrifices compromises or pay a price in
order to get what they want the scenes
of Imperial opposition as well aren't
cartoonish instead it focuses on the
Nuance of bureaucratic politics and how
individuals striving for power can
create tyrannical overreach these are
what feel like real world Stakes that
are more relevant to our lives it's not
about being plucked out of obscurity and
trained for greatness it isn't just a
simple commitment to fight against a
pure image of evil it's a world where
you have to choose between two different
values that you hold that have suddenly
come into conflict because of external
factors that are outside of your control
I won't have peace
I'll be worrying about you all the time
it's love you know like stuff we have to
deal with as humans sometimes ultimately
Andor is a well-constructed well-written
suspenseful sci-fi spy Thriller
that also happens to be a Star Wars show
thanks so much for watching I want to
talk about two things real quick if you
want to help support my content you can
go to patreon.com
thomasflight when you become a patron
you can get access to cool perks like a
monthly podcast where I give a short
spoiler-free review of everything that I
watch there's a bunch of bonus videos on
there and writing things that you can't
find anywhere else if you've been
enjoying my work I'd appreciate it if
you consider becoming a patron and
supporting my channel directly I also
want to tell you about my podcast Cinema
of meaning that I do with fellow video
essayist Tom Vanderlinden from the
channel like stories of old every week
we discuss a movie and we really try to
dive into not just the technical aspects
or reviewing the film but kind of dive
into a deeper thematic exploration of
what we think is going on in the film
we've discussed a bunch of great movies
already and I've really been enjoying
these discussions with Tom so I'd be
happy if you check it out if that sounds
interesting to you the links will be in
the description but you can also search
for Cinema of meaning wherever you find
podcasts thanks so much for watching
this video and again special thank you
to my patrons for making this video
possible
[Music]
[Music]